hey everyone it's Jasmine and I love
hosting dinner parties and as much fun
as it is to get all your friends
together to entertain I know it can be a
little bit stressful a little bit
daunting so today I'm going to show you
some easy foolproof tips so you can host
like a pro let's get started
[Music]
so it's the day before the dinner party
and we're gonna make a few crafts to
decorate our dinner table we're first
going to be making these clay napkin
rings and then these clay candle holders
they're super cute and add a
personalized touch to your dinner table
so we're going to start by making our
clay napkin rings I have two colors of
clay here this one's the white and I'm
just going to add a few Globs to my
board and then some Terracotta clay here
just sprinkle it randomize it it'll all
look beautiful once together that looks
good so we're going to place it back
onto our board
and we're just going to roll it out to a
quarter inch thick
okay oh
looks good now so now we have a ruler
here I'm just going to place it right
here and we're just going to draw a
straight line all the way down same
thing on the other side now we're just
going to cut this down on either side so
we have straight lines we're going to
cut this in half now we're going to take
either side overlap it and just pinch it
closed ta-da super easy super cute truly
there's no way to mess this up and we're
just going to let it air dry overnight
with my scraps here I'm going to combine
this into a ball and show you how I make
my candle holders we're just going to
roll this up into a nice fine
sphere
I split my ball into two and I'm just
rounding these out and we're going to
take our candle and stick it directly
inside and since it air dries a little
bit smaller you want to kind of roll it
out so there's a little more space and
it will fit tomorrow we're going to do
the same thing with this one and we're
going to let it dry overnight I actually
made some yesterday so once these air
dry they'll look like this they're super
cute they just look very rustic you know
I'd buy something like this off Etsy
it's super artsy and it just adds that
extra touch to your hosted dinner party
so the next craft we're going to be
making is ice dyed napkins super cool
super easy we're going to start with a
baking sheet on the bottom and a wire
rack over a tray and I have a couple of
damp napkins here we're just going to
scrunch them up ever so slightly over
the tray
do the same with your other napkin this
one is super cool and really easy
honestly and same thing with this one
you can't mess up it'll look amazing
promise
and you can customize it to your
favorite colors which is also great so
if you're doing a themed party and you
have colors go ahead and do that now
that these are all scrunched up I'm
going to place a bunch of ice all over
them
feel free to be generous with this and
make sure to wear gloves because working
with dye you may stain your hands now
we're going to sprinkle on some powdered
dye blues and greens in random spots
moving on to my next color here
and just be free-spirited with this
it'll turn out beautiful I promise so
when the ice starts to melt it'll leave
this really cool tie-dye effect and
that's what's going to give it that
design now that I've done all of this
I'm going to bring this outside let all
the ice melt then let it air dry bring
it back in run it under the sink until
all the color runs clear before washing
it I made some yesterday and this is
what it looks like look how cool it is
it's kind of like this aquamarine Vibe I
really like the coastal look they're
beautiful and they just add a pop of
color to the dinner table
so it's the day of the dinner party our
guests are arriving in a few hours and
we're going to begin our flower
arrangements for the table you can use
some flower frogs here we have glass and
a metal one but they also come in
different materials and you can also use
these Bud vases for simple and really
adorable Arrangements look at these I
love them so one hack I have is to pull
the vase close to the table hold your
flower against it to see what height
you'd like it to stand at and then we're
just going to cut out a diagonal today
we're going to be using the metal frog
and it'll go inside the base but I'll
demonstrate out here all you do is put
it in your desired place and shove it
right in and it'll stay intact I'm just
going to pick this up and put it into
our vase and I have some tack on the
bottom to hold it down so what I like to
do is start with some Show Stoppers that
looks good so now I have some other
flowers and I'm just gonna fill them in
and get it all evenly dispersed I really
love that the flower frogs keep
everything in place and I like to get
flowers with different kinds of textures
it just makes it look more vibrant and
there you have it a beautiful flower
arrangement is going to stay in its
place and last thing we're going to do
is add in some water beautiful
okay it's time to set the table for our
dinner party today we have four people
coming and we're going to be having a
main with a salad wine and water so
we're going to start with a large plate
with a salad plate on top we have a cute
little handmade menu right here and this
just adds a little extra to the dinner
table got some cute little hand-drawn
art on there and just a good overall
view of what everyone will be eating at
the dinner party next we got our
hand-dyed napkins in our handmade napkin
ring we're just going to place it on top
next we got our utensils the salad fork
will be on the outer left side and the
main Fork will be on the inner left side
and our knife on the right side with the
blade facing towards the plates for our
cups we're going to place the water
glass above the knife and our wine glass
just to the right of that and there you
have it the table is set it looks
complicated but it was actually pretty
easy to do and very straightforward now
onto the food
so now I'm going to show you how I like
to display the dishes on the table for
starters I really love this
Mediterranean hummus this is an awesome
way to upgrade some store-bought hummus
and just display it differently and
beautifully
so I've already laid out some hummus
here with some rainbow carrots on the
side and we're just going to add some
toppings to make it extra fancy first
I'm going to lay out some cucumber
slices adds a nice crunch to everything
nice and vibrant and just add some color
next I'm going to add in some sun-dried
tomatoes I love the red it brings to
this dish next we're going to top it
with some feta some night light sprinkle
oh that looks so pretty
next we're going to top it with some
pine nuts yes we are going very fancy
here and some mint last but not least
we're going to drizzle on some olive oil
there you have it some Mediterranean
hummus I love the vibrancy of the
toppings on here people are going to
look at this and say wow let me take a
photo of that and that's the goal these
are all done I'm going to place them
right over here
beautiful so another appetizer I love
are these fig and whipped ricotta
crostinis they're so so cute and
delicious figs are in season right now
and whenever I can use local and in
season produce when hosting others
that's an extra plus these are so good
the whipped ricotta is so fluffy topped
with the honey and balsamic glaze
so so delicious so for the show stopping
main I love to make this beef tenderloin
paired with fresh herbs a creamy
horseradish dressing one thing I love to
do is slice them beforehand plate it
with some fresh herbs and the sauce on
the side that way no one needs to worry
about cutting the meat and honestly it
makes for some really great presentation
one of my favorite sides to make for
dinner parties are these gorgeous potato
roses this is just a really fun and
unique way to elevate the presentation
of roasted potatoes and while they look
super complicated to make they're
actually pretty easy for beginners and I
just love to place them on a cake dish
so it looks like another bouquet of
flowers on your table all right time for
some salad I love to add a big salad to
my table when I'm hosting a dinner party
honestly we need some greens I love to
add in some fresh fruit some nuts for
texture very flavorful veggies like
fennel got some onion avocado for
creaminess this is just overall a great
way to add vibrancy to the table for
presentation and in flavor
for dessert I love to do a DIY parfait
for my dinner parties it lets guests get
creative and customized to their liking
and also give them a taste of everything
you can display it however you'd like
but for me I love to use a variety of
different colorful bowls I've already
built some over here on the table I
added some of my favorites which was all
of them all the brownies all the
cheesecake berries fudge caramel
chocolate chips literally everything
because that's what makes it taste so
good I also added some whipped cream on
top this is just one way to do it but
you can get really creative and come up
with different themes you can do ice
cream sundaes chocolate fondue honestly
the possibilities are endless final
setup for the dinner is complete I lit
some candles poured some water and of
course some wine cheers
all right I hope these tips were helpful
and show that with just a little bit of
preparation and creativity anyone can
throw their first dinner party like a
pro let me know in the comments below if
you have any dinner party tips to share
oh my my guests are here uh you got this
bye